Der Mobilfunkstandard 5G - wird alles bisher
dagewesene in den Schatten stellen - und zwar
nicht nur bezüglich der Datenrate, sondern
auch in Sachen Kapazität und Latenzzeit.
Und somit also blitzschnelle Reaktionen im
Netz möglich machen.
Damit werden Blockchain, das Internet der
Dinge oder das Autonome Fahren vollkommen
neue Dimensionen erreichen.
Clixoom Science & Fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science Videos.
Nur wenn ihr den Kanal abonniert verpasst
ihr kein Video.
herzlich willkommen
Vielen Dank für diesen spannenden Themenvorschlag,
den ihr mir per Whats App geschickt habt!
Der Link zu meiner persönlichen Nummer findet
ihr in der Videobeschreinung.
10 Gigabit pro Sekunde (GBit/s), also 10.000
Megabit pro Sekunde (Mbit/s), soll die Übertragungsbandbreite
des neuen Mobilfunkstandards 5G sein - das
sind wirklich unvorstellbare Geschwindigkeiten!
Denn das Höchste der Gefühle sind bei den
derzeitigen LTE-Netzen im Regelbetrieb 300
Mbit/s und die meisten Smartphone-Nutzer haben
gerade mal Tarife mit maximal 50 Mbit/s.
Nur, um es noch mal richtig deutlich zu machen:
Mit 5G könnte man einen Film rund 600 Mal
schneller laden als mit dem besten DSL-Anschluss.
Wow!
Doch nicht nur diese 5G-Datenraten haben es
in sich.
5G soll vor allem die Laufzeit der Signale
im Netz verkürzen.
Und zwar im Vergleich zu LTE um den Faktor
40.
Die sogenannte Latenz, also Signalverzögerung,
liegt dann bei nur noch einer Millisekunde
oder weniger.
In der Praxis bedeutet das: Anwendungen, die
über das Internet gesteuert werden, haben
so dermaßen kurze Reaktionszeiten, dass sie
nicht mehr vom Menschen wahrnehmbar sind.
Vorbei sind Verzögerungen bei Gesprächen,
bei denen man sich deshalb ständig ins Wort
fällt.
Total nervig ist das.
Und das ist nicht nur für Gespräche oder
Gamer, sondern vor allem für die Industrie
total spannend.
Denken wir mal an Autos, die in Echtzeit kommunizieren
oder aber Mensch-Maschine-Interaktionen.
Also an virtuelle und erweiterte Realität:
VR bzw. AR (Augumented Reality).
So könnten beispielsweise Servicetechniker
die benötigten Instruktionen über Datenbrille
eingeblendet bekommen.
Bei der ganzen 5G-Geschichte hat die Bundesnetzagentur
eine wichtige Aufgabe.
Sie ist dafür verantwortlich, dass das Frequenz-Vergabe-Verfahren
objektiv und transparent ablaufen.
Dazu heißt es auf der Website: “Die Digitalisierung
schreitet zügig voran.
Damit einher geht eine wachsende Nachfrage
nach hohen Datenraten bei zunehmender Mobilität
der Verbraucher.
Für zukunftsfähige digitale Infrastrukturen
sind den Marktteilnehmern geeignete Frequenzen
frühzeitig und bedarfsgerecht bereitzustellen.(...)
Damit soll ein schneller, flexibler und bedarfsgerechter
5G-Rollout in Deutschland ermöglicht werden.”
Doch welche Technik dahinter?
Zum einen muss für 5G die Anzahl der Antennen
deutlich erhöht werden - in einer Zelle könnten
sich dann mehr Antennen befinden als Nutzer.
Der Fachbegriff für solche Antennensysteme
heißt übrigens “Massive Multiple Input
Multiple Output”, kurz: Massive MIMO.
Zudem werden die Netze für 5G dichter werden
müssen, sodass der mittlere Abstand zwischen
den Basisstationen deutlich kleiner sein wird
als bei LTE.
Für die Datenübertragung müssen dann höhere
Frequenzen genutzt werden, denn das derzeit
genutzte Frequenzspektrum zwischen 0,8 und
2,6 Gigahertz ist voll.
Konkret geht es um den Bereich von 6 bis 300
Gigahertz - und wird somit auch als Millimeterwellen-Technologie
bezeichnet.
Ein weiterer Punkt ist die dezentrale Organisation
der Mobilfunknetze.
Konkret bedeutet das, dass bestimmte Daten
aus einer Funkzelle direkt in der dazugehörigen
Station gefiltert und verarbeitet werden und
eben nicht weit verschickt werden.
Zu den technischen Voraussetzungen heißt
es von der Bundesnetzagentur: “"Wir gehen
mit unseren Versorgungsauflagen an die Grenze
des wirtschaftlich Zumutbaren und rechtlich
Möglichen.
Wir verpflichten jeden Anbieter bis Ende 2022
mindestens 500 Stationen zusätzlich zu den
Auflagen für Straßen und Haushalte für
5G aufzubauen.
Wir sprechen also beispielsweise bei drei
Anbietern von 1500 Stationen in Deutschland,
mit denen der neue Mobilfunkstandard eingeführt
werden muss.
Außerdem müssen die Anbieter jeweils weitere
500 Masten aufstellen, mit denen sie mindestens
100 Megabit pro Sekunde in ländlichen Regionen
die Versorgung verbessern."
Doch Fachleute sind sich einig, dass LTE noch
nicht mal richtig ausgereift ist und sich
somit ein 5G-Supernetz langsam entwickeln
wird.
Auf dem Weg dorthin könnte auch 4,5G ein
Zwischenschritt sein.
Zumindest das Mobilfunknetz für den Mainstream
wird wohl mindestens noch die nächsten fünf
Jahre 4G bleiben.
Ab 2020 rechnen Experten dann mit ersten 5G-Inseln
für bestimmte Anwendungen.
Die Auktion der 5G-Frequenzen ist laut Bundesnetzagentur
jedenfalls für das erste Quartal 2019 angesetzt.
Ob dabei noch andere Unternehmen neben Vodafone,
Telekom und Telefonica für die Frequenzen
bieten werden, ist noch offen.
Bis Ende 2022 müssen dann aber mindestens
98 Prozent der Haushalte mit einer Datenrate
von 100 Megabit pro Sekunde versorgt werden.
Bislang galt das Ziel für die drei großen
etablierten Netzbetreiber, mindestens 97 Prozent
der Haushalte mit 50 Mbit/s zu versorgen - und
zwar bis 2020.
Der erfolgreiche Bieter muss dann auch dafür
sorgen, dass bis Ende 2022 alle Bundesstraßen
und Autobahnen mit 100 Mbit/s versorgt sind.
Das wird wirklich eine absolute Revolution.
Wir werden vollkommen neue Apps, Software
und Webseiten mit ziemlich ausgeklügelten
Anwendungen haben.
Ich bin schon extrem gespannt.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu und zu allen anderen
Themen verpassen wollt, dann abonniert auch
den englischen Clixoom-Kanal.
Dafür einfach hier klicken.
Auch da gibt es die ein oder andere Videopremiere!
Hier geht es weiter mit: Star Treks Tractor
Beam becomes reality - Objects can float!
See you soon - stay tuned!